hey Ryan cheryl hickey nice to see you
what's a peachy caca I get it it's a
it's amazing I don't know what a peachy
caca is though it's you dish if it yeah
or what you know for pitchy caca we're
like oh darn it or I think it's like you
know it means like oh it's nothing
okay I liked it just nothing special
with me okay good well you're a really
good dancer and you're a really good
singer um did your mom put you into
dancing and singing lessons were you
when you were really really young or did
you develop being this good at it on
this movie no my mother did not put me
in it right my uncle one day when I was
eight decided he was going to be an
Elvis impersonator and he committed to
it with more commitment than I've ever
seen any performer commit to anything
and the whole family rallied around him
and we he built this act and was a lot
of fun when it was over I thought you
know well you know what now so I kind of
got into dance after that because it
just there was a dance studio in my town
and it felt like a way to just keep the
keep it going keep it going
you it's every I think I mean I'm a
mother of two it's every mother's dream
that your son would be in a musical
what's your mom really excited to hear
that you're going to do a musical my
mother's excited but no one's more
excited than my sister who as was a
musical theater student grew up watching
musical theater studying it went to New
York to pursue it loves it so
you know I really wasn't that I mean I
only knew it because of her and through
osmosis to me but no one's happier right
now and she is so you're the lullaby
singer at home then I assume well I'll
try
thanks Ryan have fun